we've been very heavy on the documentary
the last dance which I'm pleased to talk
about with with our next guest should he
so choose we're also gonna be talking
about his new show DC's star girl which
is premiering tomorrow at 8 p.m. on the
CW enjoyed his work in the bottle rock
at the Royal Tenenbaums in old school
he's Luke Wilson how are you Luke I'm
hanging to talk to you good to chat with
you have you been watching this
documentary it's all good if you haven't
your documentary that's the one yeah no
I mean I just got a text
I've been taping them but for some
reason I only have four through now nine
so I think I wanted to start at the
beginning but I might just start at four
I got I don't know I don't know what's
going on but it's one of those things
where yeah you feel it's like a
zeitgeist saying I feel left out because
I haven't seen it it's taken over for
tiger King which I which I did not say
well here's here's what I want to tell
you Luke and I'll just treat it gingerly
they break up at the end I hope I don't
spoil it for you yeah okay but no I
can't wait to see it I was talking to a
friend in Dallas yesterday and it said
it has stuff about Jordan's father and
yeah I just always you know like
everybody else just loved him and yeah I
can't wait to see it and just such an
interesting dynamic with you know Phil
Jackson and all those other players and
yeah just I can't wait to see it but
pardon me for not being up to date on it
you know what look there's life and and
not everybody is able to just sit around
and watch television the whole day no no
I can't I just I just I don't know what
happened believe I've got the time I
love it you know and it's funny my old
SportsCenter days popped up right at the
end there has have you watched have you
just been coming across just watching
and Quarantine just chilling out some of
any of your old work any points I have
noticed like I've been like yeah they
really show Legally Blonde a lot but you
have seen old school on there a few
times too but it's funny what they're
showing on like you must be
or the the golf channel I had to my
brother Andrew another friend texted me
at the same time and they said yeah
watching Jax press conference from 86
after he won the Masters it's incredible
you know they were talking about it like
it was happened that's how kind of
sports starved they were but I mean I
was bummed out I missed I didn't know
about that Seminole match I've just been
waiting for that one with tiger and Phil
and Peyton and that's nice medium it's
that's that Seminole match yesterday was
cool-looking yeah it was it was hey Luke
if you want alerts I can give you all
those yeah if you need some I can give
you some alerts here peanut I don't I
really don't know how I missed the
Seminole one I've never heard of it yeah
they went down yesterday with Dustin
Johnson and Rory McIlroy and Matt wolf
and whoa yeah and Rick highlights but it
looks cool and Seminoles such a cool
course cool just to see those pros out
there on I mean I think it's kind of
known for being maybe a little shorter
course but are you gone Luke are you
gone yeah a ton of golf yeah okay talk
we would walk me through your game here
what's your game like my game is um kind
of but it gets called a hook a lot I can
I call it a power draw no but now I've
just been playing for a while but yeah
just that's probably what I follow most
along with just the Dallas Cowboys but
yeah I've missed been missing you know
when this all started I think there was
that Players Championship was when they
just canceled right in the middle of the
ass correct like well at least you know
we'll be able to watch the Masters when
this is all going on even if there are
no fans there and that's that's when
that's when it was a sports wise it was
a real bummer when they started to
cancel the majors Luke Wilson here on
the Rich Eisen show I know your brother
Owen was a Cowboys fan I didn't know is
that is that a family thing the cop in
Dallas and so grew up following them you
know we were from that kind of Tom
Landry Rodgers style back here
when we were kids so yeah still still
cowboys fans and just kind of hope they
can get it going again it's been quite a
quite a drought since the aiklen days
that's right Aikman and I work with
Michael Irvin all the time he's quite
the character I've gotten to run into
urban here and they're out in LA and I
go on the Fox lot he was my favorite
player so it's so cool to get the chance
to meet him and talk with him so who is
the who's the guy that you've met either
through work or whatever where
sports-wise where it was like that is
that's the coolest that right there is
he's pretty cool um well for starters
those guys have always been they always
seem pretty nice I mean got to talk to
Peyton Manning a little once up at the
Pebble pro-am and he was such a good guy
and had been around Tiger a couple of
times so pretty incredible to see you
know somebody like Tiger up close I mean
I guess it's kind of a Jordan ask figure
where I mean you feel almost badly
because you know you're standing there
looking at them like you look at a
statue you know we're just cus thinking
like gosh could one person have
accomplished everything this guy's done
and just to see how they carry
themselves you know socially is
interesting because they're so focused
but yeah all those guys have been pretty
nice when I met him all those all the
golfers up Dustin Johnson is a great guy
Pat Perez is a total character yes yeah
just probably been around those golfers
more than anybody else
Luke Wilson here on the Rich Eisen show
before we talk about your current
project who's the who's the person
actor/actress who you've been in a lot
of funny movies who just was who cracks
you up who's the one that is the
funniest that you've been around um I
think probably it really does have to be
will Ferrell I mean have done a few
things with them you know over the years
and just been friends with them but you
know it's like when I
always said about those like the SNL
people you know from like Sandler to
Tracy Morgan and Kristen Wiig I mean
it's like you know when somebody says
yeah this friend of mine is really funny
there are those people and then there
are those people like the SNL people
like will and Sandler where they've I've
always said like they seem like pro
athletes in terms of how sharp and quick
they are and just you know doing voices
and making fun of you and they can form
somebody else
um but yeah will was probably the person
where I would have to kind of focus
during scenes to not start laughing and
he's one of those guys where you kind of
look into his eyes during a scene and
it's like looking into the eyes of a
crazy person and you know I I feel like
with me sometimes he'd see like okay
I've got this guy on the ropes he's
going to start laughing and then he'd
really he'd really put the pedal down
and I started doing this thing and I
just told him I did it with him where I
would start you know it's like they do
his angle then they do my angle and he'd
be off-camera and I would just look at
like his hairline er down at his chin I
would just stop looking at his eyes
because I would feel like you just make
me start to laugh but yeah and Sandler
and Tracy Morgan too are just incredible
I mean Tracy Morgan's one of those guys
where you know he'll be just doing kind
of bits all day on set and then you hear
him on Howard Stern and he's doing the
exact same and you're like this guy's
just constantly like working on material
work and shopping it's workshopping it
he's workshop but just making it seem
like he's having a conversation with you
I mean I may be on the flip side what
was it like being on the set with Gene
Hackman you're in the Royal Tenenbaums
what was that I mean he's probably he's
along with maybe Nick Nolte probably
that the greatest actor I've ever gotten
to work with and yeah that that thing
I'm sure you've had it happen where when
you get the chance to work
those people you've grown up watching or
just you know I can remember what a huge
fan of Gene Hackman my dad was but yeah
gene was really cool guy and I
especially feel lucky now since he's one
of those guys you know like Nicholson
where they just you know I think they
just kind of quietly without any fanfare
just kind of stopped working so you
never know when it's going to happen
with those guys but gene was really cool
guy really intense never left set you
know would just sit there all day and
and was fun to talk to about you know me
would talk to you about his past and
getting started and you know different
people had worked with and yeah just a
really really cool guy and I was just
watching some of the French Connection
just over the week yeah yeah I was
channel surfing just his portrayal of
Popeye Doyle is just incredible I mean
they'll pick your feet in Poughkeepsie
but to me Hooters Hooters is my favorite
sports movie of all time that's number
one for me and him is coach Dale and
that movie is the greatest it's
incredible and I did a sports movie in
the fall and Texas called 12 mighty
orphans and that was one of the first
thing I mean I always I feel completely
familiar with Hoosiers but I was like
well I'll just I'll just watch it again
just to see if there's anything I miss
but yeah it's so good and he plays such
a cool character and then that whole
backstory about having that kind of
Woody Hayes type incident with a player
and and then like mmm at Dennis Hopper
character how he kind of helps him out
it's all really cool Luke Wilson here on
the Rich Eisen show all right before I
let you go tell me about your latest
project DC's star girl premieres
tomorrow night 8:00 p.m. on the CW I'll
give you the floor from that I'd never
really I mean I feel like you know
talking about the movies had done kind
of every genre it had done kind of like
westerns and you know romantic comedies
and dramas but had never worked on one
of these superhero projects so yeah I
play this character Pat Dugan who was
the the sidekick to a super
named storm and I mean I'd always say
like you reminded me of like like the
equipment managers in high school like I
always like those guys just because they
might you know they might not be right
for the team but they wanted to be a
part of the team and still like going to
NBA games I'll always like check out the
equipment managers cuz all thinking ship
like that guy gets a ring too like how
cool is that um so yeah I kind of played
the equipment manager to this to these
superheroes and then there's a big
battle they all die and it's 20 years
later and I'm I'm just a mechanic and
moved my family from LA to admit Braska
to kind of pick up the trail of these
villains and then my my stepdaughter
discoveries kind of all this old
superhero gear and somehow it works for
her and that's kind of the the premise
but for the show but yeah even though
it's called star girl it's got some
incredible action and I think it'll
appeal to a lot of your listeners and
viewers and you I I look forward to it
Luke now that the last dance is over I
got my dance cards a little bit more
open you know what I mean so it's it's
over and again spoiler alert they break
up at the end but I failed still think
it's worth a journey for you Luke I
really do yeah I can't wait to you I
can't wait to watch it as soon as I get
those first three episodes I'll get on
it thanks a ton for having me on man and
thanks for being on the air I appreciate
you saying that Luke let's do it again
let's do it again you know yeah even
your family be well that's Luke Wilson
DC star girl again 8:00 Eastern on the
CW hey you watched all the way to the
end thanks for that watch more right
here